so Marvel Studios went and confirmed
publicly in their latest trailer for
Loki season 2 probably the biggest
question that we've wanted an answer to
since Loki season 1 and that is if
Mobius has ever ridden a jet ski before
and they confirmed that in this trailer
however the big question now is are we
ultimately going to see Mobius ride the
jet ski the TVA is gone I think you mean
ATV and no we got in two of them last
week essentially for the first time as
well since arm Mobius his memories got
wiped away and he has no recollection of
riding a jet ski before in his life his
past life as a actual human on the
timeline so it would be his first time
so the new question is are we going to
see the mobies that we have come to know
and love over these past two seasons
ride the jety himself or simply see his
past life his past variant ride the jet
ski what's going on everybody welcome
back to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren
Thompson and today Marvel Studios put
out a midseason trailer basically
showing us a ton of footage that we have
not seen that is going to pop up in
episode 5 and in episode 6 and this
basically confirms the big theory that
we've had about what is going to happen
after episode 4 and it looks like they
pretty much have showed us this and
confirmed our Theory we also do have
some details about what exactly is going
to happen in episode 5 don't worry there
aren't any Major Spoilers for what
exactly is going to happen but we have
some pretty good details to share with
you today plus Marvel showed all of
these new seen so of course we have to
break him down so if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
videos and breakdowns also there's only
2 days left in our giveaway for October
if you want a chance to win an Xbox
series X A PS5 some Marvel Legends items
or some DC items all you have to do is
subscribe to the channel and leave a
comment down below that automatically
enters you in our giveaway the winner
gets to pick one item and we pick one
winner at the end of each month we do
this giveaway every month so after
episode 4 we did a video talking about
what we believed was going to be
happening after episode 4 obviously
everybody wasn't going to die and the
show wasn't about to end not with two
episodes left and there was footage that
we still have not seen happen yet and
now we have even more footage but our
video was a theory about Loki time
traveling Loki is basically going to be
stuck in a Time Loop until he can
ultimately with the help of his team
figure out how to get the time Loom to
be stable and not explode and it looks
like he's going to be trying many
different times in fact we even see in
this new trailer he'll be working with
Victor timley again and it looks like
Victor timley still again goes out with
the space suit on to try and fix the
time Loom and get spaghettified once
again in fact we see a lot of new images
of a lot of different parts of the TVA
getting spaghettified and what is
happening here is this is when the time
limit explodes and the rest of the TVA
basically gets spaghettified itself but
if you notice in this new footage Loki
is still time slipping we thought they
had figured out the ultimate cure for
his time slip but it doesn't appear to
be so and that is a great thing because
that is ultimately what is going to save
Loki now we knew that Loki was going to
be able to travel to different points in
time in the TVA something that is not
supposed to be possible but he did with
his time slipping now in episode one he
mentioned that the door that he got
kicked through the door that Sylvie
kicked him through at the end of time
was created by he who remains his temp
pad Loki stole it and used it to send
Loki away so perhaps that is why he was
time glitching and perhaps that is why
he can actually go to different points
in time at the TVA which is not supposed
to be possible but as we've mentioned
before he who remains creative the TVA
and we've learned from Kang in Quantum
Mania that he can definitely control
time he said it's a box and once you
break out it's really not what you think
and you can control it so even though
the TVA exists outside of SpaceTime it's
very clear from what we've seen in
season 2 and what we've seen from the
new footage that we got today Loki is
going to be traveling through different
points in time in the TVA which means
he's going to get another chance to
essentially fix the time Loom to where
it doesn't explode and kill everybody
and destroy the TVA so one particular
scene that we get is where Loki actually
goes to the timeline and he finds Mobius
he finds him before Kang took him he
finds his actual life and where is he
working at a pow sports dealership
selling jet skis so just like we thought
when we saw the very first trailer when
Loki time glitches to piranha pow Sports
Mobius is in the background selling jet
skiis and to confirm this they show us
Loki going up to Mobius saying the TVA
is gone and he says I think you mean ATV
and no we got two of them in last week
so keep in mind this is a Mobius on the
timeline he's going to have no knowledge
of the TVA whatsoever but in another
scene in this trailer it looks like this
particular Mobius is going to eventually
wind up at the TVA because he is wearing
the same clothes that we see him wearing
here however this doesn't really make
too much sense why would Loki take a
Mobius who has no knowledge of the TVA
whatsoever back to the TVA to help
what's more than likely Happening Here
is that he actually takes Mobius the one
that he has come to know and that we
have come to know over the past two
seasons down to a timeline to see what
his life was and why he loves jety so
much because he used to sell them and
Mobius probably dressed up in the same
type of outfit as him to probably not be
noticed or something along those lines
because it makes more sense for the Mobi
that we know to be in those clothes
rather than Loki taking a Mobius who has
no knowledge of the TVA whatsoever to
the TVA now what's really interesting
about this trailer is that it's actually
reflective on what exactly is going to
happen in the next two episodes we've
heard that episode 5 is going to be a
lot of exploration of the timeline of
seeing what people's lives were actually
like we see footage of Casey here and of
course we see footage of Mobius and
essentially we're going to see what all
of the TVA Employees lives were like on
the timeline in episode 5 it looks like
Loki is going to be time glitching there
and it looks like Loki right when he's
about to die at the TVA where we left
off in episode 4 time glitches right to
Mobius because the first thing that he
says to him is that the TVA is gone so
it doesn't appear that he has time
slipped back to a past time in the TVA
yet but we know that that's what's going
to happen we know that essentially he is
stuck in a Time Loop and time is going
to repeat itself until Loki figures out
a way to fix the time Loom once and for
all and that's kind of what this trailer
does because this trailer is showing us
new footage but it's also showing us a
lot of old footage from the previous
episodes but that is done very
intentionally because they're going to
repeat this could actually be new
footage except it is past footage
repeating itself if you're following but
this trailer opens with time at the TVA
repeating itself it shows us Loki
appearing in the TVA essentially
starting over we hear OB stating Loki
how much do you know and he says let's
assume I don't know much but I'm a quick
learner and I'm a God and then Casey
says well let's start at the beginning
that is going to be a big concept exep
moving forward in Loki season 2 Loki is
going to continuously fail and then
start over at the beginning and this is
a scene that we have not seen before so
we know that it is new and we know Loki
is time glitching back in time but we
still believe one main thing that this
is a part of he who remains' plan in
fact it could be he who remains that is
making Loki time glitch perhaps he's not
really time slipping but he who remains
himself is sending him to different
points in time he who remains probably
cannot return to the TVA until the time
Loom is fixed and he knows that Loki is
the one who has to do it so this all
could still very well be orchestrated by
he who remains because one interesting
thing that we see here is that he is
indeed again working with Victor timley
Victor timley suits up again dies again
and we're probably going to see this
happen a bunch of times until ultimately
Loki decides that he is the one that has
to go out there and do it himself
because he is a god he's probably
stronger his body is probably stronger
than normal humans in fact of of course
we know that it is so Loki even without
a suit is more likely to be able to
handle that temporal energy so
ultimately it might end up being Loki
who goes out there to fix the time Loom
which is probably a part of he who
remains his plan but that now begs the
question what happens to Victor timely
can he who remains transfer his
Consciousness into Victor timley and
then become a king the Conqueror and
take over the TVA as it is right then
and there that is the big question
moving forward how does he who remains
return and what happens to Victor timley
will he be good or bad either way we
know that Loki is about to be stuck in a
Time Loop until he can get it right and
we are about to see what everybody's
lives were really like on Earth again
hopefully our Mobius gets to ride that
jet ski fingers crossed but in the
meantime let us know what you think
about all of this new footage in the
comments down below and if you have any
theories be sure to let us know as well
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe to stay up to date on the
latest MCU news you can also follow us
on Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof